Yeah, the really the only successful was
the first one. It did achieve its
mission. It liberated you know Jerusalem
and you and it and not just Jerusalem
but various they had various counties um
and the first one being Adessa and
principalities. So they you know they
carved a whole niche that became part of
Christendom and pilgrims were allowed to
come and whatnot. But then after that
yeah I mean every other crusade the
second was a complete disaster. The
third had made minimal gains with King
Richard. Um, but it it didn't it didn't
rein Jerusalem, but it made good gains
because right before it, right before
the third crusade, it looked like
Saladin was going to completely eject
the crusaders once and for all.
>> That was his goal. But with the with the
third, that's the second most successful
uh King Richard actually gave kind of a
breathing space back to the Christians
and reunions.
Um, and then, you know, the fourth
crusade is neither here nor there. I
just went spun off course completely.
>> Well, they sacked Constantinople.
>> That's the one where they sacked
Constantinople and I mean that's the big
aha moment that everyone loves to like
harp on, you know, the fourth crusade
and it's just uh I don't find it as
remarkable as most people think. Um if
you really look at it, uh it started off
as a normal crusade and you had all
these crus various crusaders I think
from France wanted um you know
commission Venice to build a lot of
ships for them. But when the time came,
only one-third of the crusaders actually
showed up. The rest came to the Holy
Land. I think they were going to Egypt
again. That was the target. But they
went through different routes and they
couldn't pay. And the, you know, the
Venetians just insisted. So the
Venetians kind of said, "All right, you
know, we'll forgive the debt, but come
help us conquer these guys,
>> um, fellow Christians who were creating
problems for Venice." Um the long story
short though is the pope was completely
against all this you know and if you're
if you're going to judge an institution
you have to look at its head not the
individuals who go off you know go off
on their own thing and a lot of the
Christians even from when they made this
pact left so it was a small core that
went and sacked this I think it's Zora
um on behalf of Venice and then long
story short you know they still were
trying to go and they ended up you know
making an alliance with some ousted
Byzantine prince
and uh you know and they helped him and
this goes on for two years but then they
don't get what he said they should get
um the reward or whatever and finally
they just ran a muck and conquered it
and they all got excommunicated. Pope
Innocent III was just completely
disgusted with the whole affair. So my
point is, you know, of course things go
off the rail, but officially the
representatives of the crusading venture
were completely against it, you know, so
these individuals did what they did. Um,
but anyway, I uh and then the fifth
crusade comes and that goes again to
Egypt and that almost won. They almost
were victorious because before long they
realized you can't you can't hold
Jerusalem without conquering Egypt.
>> And so a lot of them that's it became
the focal point. Um but that also
failed. And uh there the sixth crusade
isn't really a crusade. It's uh you know
the emperor Frederick uh I forget which
number but he actually reclaims
Jerusalem and without war and he's hated
um because the way he did it is seen
very cynical and he in fact is kind of a
cynical guy. He's a very interesting
character. I talk about him um in that
book actually. But um he kind of you
know he just mocks Christians and Jews
and Muslims and thinks they're all you
know but he'll give lip service to
whoever. Anyway, it was seen as a
cynical deal that was not good or
advantageous. And before long it all
does unravel again and and one of the
worst attacks comes soon after which
prompts the seventh crusade in 1244.
The attack by this kind of muslim
Egyptian Tatar or or they're they're
both Muslims. with some savage group the
quariz who come from the east and they
engage in some of the most obscene
atrocities against the Christians of the
holy land who are already quickly
dwindling and then you get the seventh
crusade king Louie St. Louisie another
abysmal failure you know um but the guy
meant very well that's why he became
sainted and then the eighth crusade is
him again and then he finally dies and
that fails and then you have the ninth
crusade which is very very uh small
scale and it's Prince Edward who becomes
King Edward Long Shanks um and not
>> the bad guy in
>> right in Braveheart
>> in Braveheart right right
>> who's actually kind of he seems like a
good guy though when you read um the
actual sources but um and the long
shanks apparently was very all. So
anyway, yeah, the ultimately the
Crusades were a failed venture, but when
you really look at, you know, the wise
in it, if if anything, they're actually
more impressive because of how long they
they managed to last against the odds
that they were in. Remember, this is a
small group of European Christians
traveling to the heart of the lion's den
and trying to hold on to it. You know,
the differences between the Crusades and
the Islamic conquests is the Islamic
conquests were basically we're going to
conquer anyone who's an infidel. And so
that what that meant is my immediate
neighbor, which also meant I got all the
I got all the resources. I'm I'm not
deep into enemy territory. Behind me are
all my my whole world. Right.
>> Right.
>> I have an endless supply. So I I'm here
and I conquer here and then I
consolidate. Then I go here and I
conquer. And that's exactly what they
did. But the crusaders for ideological
Christian purposes went all the way into
the heart of it and became a tiny group
that was continuously dwindling. Okay,
this is what gave rise to the military
orders who really became the heart of
it. These guys who were just so utterly
committed but and especially as Europe
became more and more secularized, the
numbers became ridiculous. So habitually
in these battles, you would get a guy
like Saladin or Bars. They would show up
with just ridiculous amounts of numbers,
which makes sense cuz this is their
homeland. They can raise any number of
armies. And the crusaders are always
limited to a few hundred,000 guys. So if
anything, it's actually remarkable that
they were able to hold out that long.